shocking images from inside uh a cramped
border this came through yesterday if
you haven't seen it don't blame yourself
it just came out
this is the facility in donna texas
showing migrants stacked wall-to-wall
many un
unaccompanied children just sitting
there laying there waiting to be
processed
texas congressman brian babin and
retired acting ice director tom homan
both toured the southern border together
jay joined us now to talk about what
they saw
because they saw a lot more than just
these images thanks to you both
congressman
you're no stranger to this area what was
different about this visit
well it it's out of control you know i
mean in spite of what the bad
administration is telling us
uh this is not a crisis even it's just a
challenge
etc we know it's a humanitarian crisis
uh not only for the migrants that were
coming in my heart just went out to some
of these children
uh in a facility there donna that should
be holding 250 and they've got 5
700 people stacked in there like
sardines
and they just don't seem to to realize
what what's going on there the border
patrol
uh as time will tell you or i think the
morale is down but they're doing a
tremendous job and
but they're they're battling with a
short stick
and then opening up the borders of the
united states of america and
absolutely uh creating this problem and
putting
americans in danger as well as these
migrants uh and the
stunning cost of what is happening there
it's just unbelievable brian i know
we're getting hotels we're converting
military bases we're taking over the
convention centers not even telling the
governors
tom it takes a lot to rattle you from
what you saw
where does this rank in outrageous
scenes at the border in your career
it's the worst because this was totally
preventable
you know the buying administration the
income administration was they said if
you if you end these programs
we're going to see a surge like you've
ever seen before they were briefed by
leadership
at ice at cbp i've talked to people that
briefed them
and and so they knew this would happen
look brian i wrote an op-ed in july of
last year saying this would happen at
the end of these policies
they knew what they were doing again
this isn't but this isn't incompetence
this isn't
you know bad management this is open
borders they
they design an open borders agenda and
that men and women and border patrol
feel abandoned because they're no longer
enforcing the law
they're facilitating illegal entry at
the instructional administration
and you saw you were telling me before
they feel abandoned but you were used
the word surge
you offended a congresswoman from queens
alexander ocasio-cortez here's what i'm
talking about
first of all just gut check
stop anyone who's using the term surge
around you consciously is trying to
invoke a militaristic frame
this is not a surge these are children
and they are not insurgents and we are
not being
invaded congressman
how dare you insult her by using the
word surge
where is she now brian why isn't she
down here i can tell you
leading this uh this delegation of texas
congressman and former professionals in
this
in this very business we actually asked
after a vice president kamala harris was
given
charge of the border situation by by
president biden
we actually invited her we invited her
to come
and visit with us at some of these spots
on our itinerary
we heard nothing whatsoever and
absolutely
while this administration is telling us
to continue to wear masks and
and only visit with just very few people
up until ja
to july they are stacking people who are
coveted positive
children on top of one another and
releasing them
into the public to fan out across texas
and across this united states
in the middle of a pandemic they they
have it
it's just hard to comprehend how they
were they can justify this
except that i think this is their plan
they want open borders they want as many
of these people to come in
and get on government assistance and
become
uh voting citizens or at least voting uh
uh you know people that would come and
continue the uh the democrat uh majority
and uh and we just can't i think people
just need to wake up and if it wasn't
for people like you brian and fox news
they would not be getting the truth and
that's what we need is the truth here
right uh tom you insulted her when you
used the warlike term surge
well she needs from dahmer to talk to
men and women to put their uniform on
every day and stand in that moment he
came down when trump was president
oh absolutely but you haven't seen her
since look the men and women of the borg
show
say it's the surge the men and women of
bournemouth shows a crisis the men and
women of bourbon should know as
brian bibin said that these cartels are
using these children and family units
to throw them across the border and tie
up their assets forty percent of border
patrols assigned to the facility no
longer on the line
so so these cartels are moving drugs and
bad people to unguarded areas
this is a national security crisis and
if she can't
understand that or accept that then she
shouldn't be in congress at all
yeah what's unbelievable is the vice
president was given this portfolio
clearly by the president she takes the
weekend off and says i'm not going to
the border
i'm going to the origin of where the
problem is uh
i don't know who's more powerful in that
administration
uh it's hard to know i don't even know
what she's doing uh but it's hard to
believe that that would be
you'd want the job and then not do the
job congressman
uh tom holman thanks so much thank you